VHACLEWahlJ: Experience and
VHACLEWahlJ: and and hope that I can.
VHACLEWahlJ: you know, add any
VHACLEWahlJ: you know, side notes, or anything that maybe could help the future work with triple.
David: Fantastic, fantastic, and just to confirm, you are comfortable if I record the screen and audio today.
David: Yes, okay, great, great. So it's all started. So could you tell me a little bit about your role at the Va. And how often you're using Cms to upload images.
VHACLEWahlJ: My role at the Va. I've worked here
VHACLEWahlJ: about a year now, and my role is in public affairs where I work with external releases
VHACLEWahlJ: including website, management, social media management and any any anything that's going out to the public facing products. So that that involves our
VHACLEWahlJ: our Va northeast Ohio healthcare system
VHACLEWahlJ: website that involves any kind of releases that we do as far as news releases with the public.
VHACLEWahlJ: And
VHACLEWahlJ: that. That's kind of the All all inclusive, what we do, just any, anything external to our external stakeholders. We're working with them, and we and we're using them. We want to communicate with them
VHACLEWahlJ: via our drupal as well as our social media, where we we merge those 2 together. So we can funnel people to the website for more information. And you know, so it's kind of a mixture of just anything
VHACLEWahlJ: that's external to the the Medical Center itself. Just the communication we want to get to to a reliable source for people to to land on, and to find their path to where they need to get support and the opportunities we provide here with the veterans.
David: Gotcha gotcha.
David: Now, what kind of
David: when you're on? va.gov, what ex?
David: When are you uploading images? For what kinds of content types.
VHACLEWahlJ: We'll work with it. For if it is a news release, typically, there's photos or images that we want to go with that release like, if there is some kind of award, or there's some kind of
VHACLEWahlJ: new thing that our research department came along, because we also have 2 research departments here.
David: It, knows.
VHACLEWahlJ: East Ohio, where that we we work with them, too. They they fall under us under the Va. So
VHACLEWahlJ: It's just a help of visual illustration and and support to that story from that perspective.
VHACLEWahlJ: And then, again, too, on on the the static pages, the web pages where we want to include a a photo of some. Maybe it's a maybe like for the research, like they'll they'll have a lot of hands or different new products that you know, you can explain in a
VHACLEWahlJ: in text, but it's gonna help the audience understand through through photos. And maybe maybe sometimes
VHACLEWahlJ: more than one photo might be beneficial to that story, or that to that, that page where people can.
VHACLEWahlJ: you know, just visually see and understand, especially for different types of learners out there that that can go onto this page and may maybe they can.
VHACLEWahlJ: Maybe that. Would that help them understand the product a little better? Maybe that will communicate a little better. So the individual side. That's another part of what we do. We're on both both sides of that. With the external releases.
David: Gotcha gotcha. Okay? So when you have external releases or like news, or something like that.
David: do you find yourself
David: like
David: picking the images that are going, are you? Is someone sharing the images that need to be uploaded to you.
VHACLEWahlJ: Both sides as far as if it is a specific branch like if it is
VHACLEWahlJ: depend depending where it's coming from it, you know.
VHACLEWahlJ: We. I don't own anything in research. We don't control any of that stuff we we might have. We have a medical media team who has photography here, so they might work with us on that aspect. So we have a controlled image imagery from that perspective.
VHACLEWahlJ: however, sometimes they there is an existing product photo that we might use.
VHACLEWahlJ: But typically on external release. If it's something that's newsworthy that we're putting out, we will. We will
VHACLEWahlJ: have more control in that photo.
VHACLEWahlJ: And and.
David: You find your.
VHACLEWahlJ: With a story.
David: Do you find yourself like cropping the images or editing these images before you're uploading them? Or do you kind of just take it at as
David: as it is.
VHACLEWahlJ: No, if if I'm putting something out there because I'm sometimes the end before it goes out, the more of the last approval area cause. That's more. My my role here, too, is also to ensure
VHACLEWahlJ: through this line that it's come through of of from medical media to photography, from the the client itself that it fits and it still describes
VHACLEWahlJ: wouldn't need to describe, because I I notice sometimes in triple things will get cut off, and there's like a a little bit lack of control.
VHACLEWahlJ: as far as how it will display on the other side.
VHACLEWahlJ: So
VHACLEWahlJ: i i i i do what I can to maybe make it fit the mold that
VHACLEWahlJ: drupal cms provides for us.
VHACLEWahlJ: But I'll do that with other other sites, too, as far as if it is a social media site like
VHACLEWahlJ: we. There's a couple of different ways. We'll need to crop things, too, that might not come out as the photographer originally intended it. But as long as it has
VHACLEWahlJ: the product in there that we need
VHACLEWahlJ: and the communication tools with it's
VHACLEWahlJ: that's what we do, too. We're just doing like a fine tune to make sure that it makes sense what's going out there as far as imagery side.
David: Got it. Got it?
David: Okay? So let's go ahead and jump into our 1st pass. Could you please open your Cms and log in
David: and then share your screen. The next prompt will be
David: having you kind of create a new page.
David: if if you're familiar with events, events would be a good one.
David: and just kind of watching your workflow as you go through that.
VHACLEWahlJ: Okay, let me.
VHACLEWahlJ: It's been a while since I use zoom. Let me make sure I got it right.
David: Yeah, I heard. Yeah, everyone we're talking to is more familiar with teams, I believe. Right?
VHACLEWahlJ: Yeah, they at at this place. My, my last place we use. Zoom.
VHACLEWahlJ: no, it's something
VHACLEWahlJ: actually before that, it was Google. But Google's restricted. Here zoom is. I I guess Zoom is working because I'm on on the site.
David: But.
VHACLEWahlJ: Everything is is through
VHACLEWahlJ: teams. Now, yeah, the that's what's kind of took on the monopoly as far as any communication tools here.
VHACLEWahlJ: Okay, screen. 2.
VHACLEWahlJ: Okay, it should be.
VHACLEWahlJ: Wait, that's you guys.
VHACLEWahlJ: these screens back together here?
VHACLEWahlJ: no, that's on it.
VHACLEWahlJ: Okay.
VHACLEWahlJ: said.
VHACLEWahlJ: is, is it? Is it displaying? Right? Are you able to.
David: I'm not seeing anything yet.
VHACLEWahlJ: Okay. 2. Okay. Share.
VHACLEWahlJ: I had to click the share button. Here we go.
David: Oh, got it
David: perfect!
VHACLEWahlJ: So now I'm in dripple. These are these are my sections.
VHACLEWahlJ: We can go up to
VHACLEWahlJ: wait. Where's
VHACLEWahlJ: we might?
VHACLEWahlJ: Oh.
VHACLEWahlJ: okay, sir, yeah.
VHACLEWahlJ: Content.
David: So yeah, of these, you're you. Which ones are you using the most, making the most of.
VHACLEWahlJ: well, we
VHACLEWahlJ: we've we've
VHACLEWahlJ: just recently I I made a whole new page. But if if it's just a page itself, if there's a specific page.
VHACLEWahlJ: I'll I'll go to that. But if it's an event.
VHACLEWahlJ: or if there's a story like a news release.
VHACLEWahlJ: We can go through there and populate the dialog boxes through throughout that. But.
David: Yeah, what? What do you most commonly use? What is more, more news releases more events.
VHACLEWahlJ: I guess it would be news news release right now. Events we've we've already established those and kind of there's there. There shouldn't be anything specifically new popping up just yet. Th. Those are typically for outreach group who who go out and have
VHACLEWahlJ: you know, appreciation days or awareness days at different locations around our
VHACLEWahlJ: or area of operations.
VHACLEWahlJ: They don't.
David: So yeah, if we can do news releases, that's that's fine. What? I'm really curious about a news release is how you upload a photo.
David: Yeah.
David: I'm using.
VHACLEWahlJ: should be okay. Let me slow it down here for a moment. There's should be A
VHACLEWahlJ: and
VHACLEWahlJ: media.
VHACLEWahlJ: So we'll put the text of the file of the story in here, and then you can also add a Pdf file in there. So then, opening up a media library, add
VHACLEWahlJ: drop files here. Select a file.
VHACLEWahlJ: me see if I can find him.
VHACLEWahlJ: Photo.
VHACLEWahlJ: We have
VHACLEWahlJ: to see if I have
VHACLEWahlJ: 1, 2, 3.
VHACLEWahlJ: Let's see.
VHACLEWahlJ: Cancel.
VHACLEWahlJ: Wow
VHACLEWahlJ: and media.
VHACLEWahlJ: So
VHACLEWahlJ: image
VHACLEWahlJ: slide file.
VHACLEWahlJ: I'll just do this one. It's fine.
VHACLEWahlJ: So
VHACLEWahlJ: this is just a file from a recent event they had in the
VHACLEWahlJ: in the Medical Center for wellness.
VHACLEWahlJ: Oh, no.
VHACLEWahlJ: And when that's uploading I just go down to
VHACLEWahlJ: are specific.
VHACLEWahlJ: Vision 10.
VHACLEWahlJ: That's it. There's in 10
VHACLEWahlJ: northeast Ohio.
VHACLEWahlJ: Apply that.
VHACLEWahlJ: The Internet's slow here. So.
David: So are you
David: uploading multiple images? Is that weird.
VHACLEWahlJ: No, it's it's 1 image.
David: Oh, it's 1 image. Okay.
VHACLEWahlJ: One jp, the the Internet is really slow.
David: Got it.
VHACLEWahlJ: I had to restart the computer a few times.
VHACLEWahlJ: even though I I do actually have a graphics computer. But but it still like struggles here. So
VHACLEWahlJ: okay.
VHACLEWahlJ: on this again. Section
VHACLEWahlJ: back to
VHACLEWahlJ: Vision 10. This is, this is where it's a little
VHACLEWahlJ: gets old, too. If you're doing a lot of things. Not not too bad. But you just want to make sure that you have everything
VHACLEWahlJ: attributed to the the correct healthcare system.
VHACLEWahlJ: yeah.
VHACLEWahlJ: Oh, sorry
VHACLEWahlJ: people.
VHACLEWahlJ: then I believe it gives you different ways to to crop the image
VHACLEWahlJ: here. So if if there wouldn't be a need to.
David: Have you ever used these before.
VHACLEWahlJ: I have
VHACLEWahlJ: to to control in at some aspect. So maybe I don't want the hand in there, or.
David: And which which of these typically is the ones you pick
David: her.
VHACLEWahlJ: Would use it.
VHACLEWahlJ: From from my
VHACLEWahlJ: experience I've only seen that you can, only you can only use one photo. So if there is a like this. This photo.
VHACLEWahlJ: which might tell a little bit of the story, may not tell all the story. Maybe there's another
VHACLEWahlJ: a member that should be in there
VHACLEWahlJ: that
VHACLEWahlJ: an instructor or somebody.
VHACLEWahlJ: It would be nice to have more than one
VHACLEWahlJ: photo available.
VHACLEWahlJ: This is free form.
David: Yeah, typically, which of these crop settings do you pick.
VHACLEWahlJ: Usually a 5 by 7 or 4 by. I guess it's not a 3 by 2.
VHACLEWahlJ: That would be just like a standard
VHACLEWahlJ: generic photo like
VHACLEWahlJ: horizontal photo that
VHACLEWahlJ: would fit seems to fit the format on drupal. The best.
David: Okay?
David: And then what's the difference between save and select and save and insert.
VHACLEWahlJ: Save and insert. We'll we'll put it into
VHACLEWahlJ: the story that you're using right now. Say, I think
VHACLEWahlJ: if I'm if I'm getting this right now, like it's been a while since
VHACLEWahlJ: I've done. I didn't do the story last time, but
VHACLEWahlJ: it's
VHACLEWahlJ: insert the way I understand it should just insert into the story, then
VHACLEWahlJ: select it
VHACLEWahlJ: you can. You can go back, and you, you can add me like this will store into a like a database
VHACLEWahlJ: that you can go back and and select later.
VHACLEWahlJ: so it would be
VHACLEWahlJ: down here. So now I could go back and
VHACLEWahlJ: selected, or
VHACLEWahlJ: please.
David: Got it.
David: Okay? Great. So overall. How was that experience for you of adding some media.
VHACLEWahlJ: which it, it seems
VHACLEWahlJ: to me, since
VHACLEWahlJ: I've only worked with Cms since since I've been at this
VHACLEWahlJ: location. But
VHACLEWahlJ: they they have it laid out to protect.
VHACLEWahlJ: you know, as restrictive as it can be to help protect
VHACLEWahlJ: and organize on probably a a larger scale. This content that goes through so that they can
VHACLEWahlJ: come through the audits. It's it's what my opinion is. I think it's slow a little bit. I wish there was a way to
VHACLEWahlJ: like, since I'm always
VHACLEWahlJ: posting from
VHACLEWahlJ: va northeast highway vision 10.
VHACLEWahlJ: I wish there was a way just to kind of make that a default setting as opposed to
VHACLEWahlJ: adding a photo and scrolling down through multiple different locations.
VHACLEWahlJ: If for each each time I want to do something, regardless of how many times. I do this a day or week, or something. I wish, though, if there were a way to expedite that, just to make a default setting for ourselves, and maybe I'm not familiar with that, too.
VHACLEWahlJ: I I wouldn't say that I'm an expert with this setting, but I've I've worked with multiple settings
VHACLEWahlJ: over a quiet of time between radio stations, between advertising locations and stuff. So
VHACLEWahlJ: it's just kind of a way of finding
VHACLEWahlJ: the the content you need and what you need to accomplish.
David: Yeah.
David: Okay, well, thank you.
VHACLEWahlJ: I just I just see it.
David: I was gonna move us on to our next. But, please if there's anything else you'd like to share
VHACLEWahlJ: No.
David: Okay, great. So going on to the next part of our
David: session. I just shared with you a link
David: in zoom chat. So if you go ahead and click that
David: it'll pull up a prototype
David: which we're currently working on.
VHACLEWahlJ: Hold on.
VHACLEWahlJ: maybe on 3 different screens here. So.
David: Oh, yeah, no, no worries. Take your time.
VHACLEWahlJ: Future.
VHACLEWahlJ: one moment.
VHACLEWahlJ: Pew.
VHACLEWahlJ: Okay.
David: Okay, perfect, perfect.
David: And I do have one quick question for you. Before we jump into this
David: when you're receiving images from folks that you need to upload for news releases or things like that.
David: Do you ever find yourself like editing them or readjusting their sizing? And like Canva Photoshop things like that.
VHACLEWahlJ: Typically, we don't have canva here. But Photoshop.
David: Photoshop.
VHACLEWahlJ: Yes.
VHACLEWahlJ: a lot of times I'll edit I because I do at times.
VHACLEWahlJ: And this has happened even beyond this location, have to edit something that's coming from a field to somebody who's not maybe proficient in
VHACLEWahlJ: photography or or understanding of communications in general, like, it's just somebody with a cell phone, they click. They were at a location. They have content that we want to share. But maybe they have a big negative space over here, or they have exit signs up here, or they they have just ambiguous
VHACLEWahlJ: things that shouldn't be that take away or detract from
VHACLEWahlJ: what we need to say. So, yeah, crop is
VHACLEWahlJ: often used before I do any release here.
David: Got it, got it? And have you ever used the built in tools in drupal to do any of that cropping? Or is it typically
David: in Photoshop or elsewhere.
VHACLEWahlJ: My comfort level is probably Photoshop
VHACLEWahlJ: because I
VHACLEWahlJ: my my career started out in design. And I've kind of I've
VHACLEWahlJ: I've kept up that proficiency. But
VHACLEWahlJ: as as I've come over to the government side, I
VHACLEWahlJ: I've I've seen various levels of proficiency in
VHACLEWahlJ: in
VHACLEWahlJ: this field, so I can understand why they have an easy tool in drupal. So I if if I'm in a hurry, though, I would still be able to use crop like like you saw me earlier whenever I was maybe restructuring the content. There, I I could do that, and a lot of times I'll I'll run out of time, too, because there's so much, so many things
VHACLEWahlJ: they are coming in from different angles that need to go out. So
VHACLEWahlJ: my preferred way would be Photoshop. But
VHACLEWahlJ: If there's an easy tool, I would definitely use that because some of the adobe programs are a little more elaborate and and extensive where
VHACLEWahlJ: the the newer tools like like Campbell or express you can. You can do extremely quick edits. So if there's something similar to that, that would
VHACLEWahlJ: that that's still beneficial.
David: Great. Okay? Well, thank you for sharing that.
David: If you go on the left nav, you'll see proposed flow as one of the options.
David: perfect.
David: And this is for events. But the the way images kind of work is is quite similar through events. News releases stories. So
David: I'd like you to imagine that you're creating a new page for an upcoming event.
David: and you have already included your
David: date for the event, the location that it's happening. And now it's time to upload an image.
David: and I'd like you to show me how you might do that.
VHACLEWahlJ: It looks like you have all the content above. So the upload image
VHACLEWahlJ: recommended
VHACLEWahlJ: same content.
VHACLEWahlJ: This is.
VHACLEWahlJ: or Vince.
VHACLEWahlJ: I guess there's no
VHACLEWahlJ: and.
David: Doing cake.
VHACLEWahlJ: Keep that.
David: Yes, and the prototype you're not. You would be able to like, move it up and down and crop it in real life. But this is a prototype. So we're not really able to do that. Okay, but yes.
VHACLEWahlJ: save a blonde.
David: So.
VHACLEWahlJ: I guess you can publish this to the National. They did have us
VHACLEWahlJ: published a series of events earlier this year. That's what how we had populated events, driven things, but.
David: So, how was that experience of just uploading the image.
VHACLEWahlJ: It was nice when I don't know if this will work on anything else but just clicking on.
VHACLEWahlJ: It's it's not even just the image, but also that any caption information.
VHACLEWahlJ: Again, if there's a way to expedite some of that, some of that content. But yes, having less less buttons, and because I think you like you asked me before, and there was a bit of confusion about what does this mean versus this meeting? And
VHACLEWahlJ: and I I feel that I have some.
VHACLEWahlJ: some cognitive ability to understand graphics and Gui interfaces. But even for myself, coming in here like there's
VHACLEWahlJ: it, it could. You could use improvement and simplifying that one button save, publish. You're done that. That was a benefit in this.
VHACLEWahlJ: In this scenario.
David: Got it, got it. So, comparing this version to the current one that you're using for uploading images.
David: what what do you like about this version?
David: What if anything? Oh.
VHACLEWahlJ: We're just
VHACLEWahlJ: with few fewer, like
VHACLEWahlJ: the ability to
VHACLEWahlJ: to click on something and have it populate.
VHACLEWahlJ: I don't. I don't know if like. The Alt text had filled itself. If that was pre.
David: Yeah, it automatically filled just because it just stimulate like you typing it in.
David: But you're saying that if it kind of automatically, just like, saw the picture, and recommended the alt text that would save you time.
VHACLEWahlJ: Definitely, because I mean, that's requirement, the 508 requirement on everything we do. And that's what we get audited on. So so some of the things you know with the current. AI, if you if you've seen any other programs, they they it can.
VHACLEWahlJ: you know, have a baseline, like a picture of a group of people in a setting, or 3 people sent you could write it. It could just at least have some pre
VHACLEWahlJ: pre completed text at some level, that if you again, if there's a way to expedite any of that, if it could, if you had AI interface or something that could just kind of be aware of the content of the photo. You could still go back and edit it, but
VHACLEWahlJ: that would that would again help expedite the situation.
David: Absolutely. Is there anything else besides that autocomplete that you like about this version
David: or this auto suggest?
David: And does.
VHACLEWahlJ: Less
VHACLEWahlJ: dialog boxes.
David: Supposedly.
VHACLEWahlJ: That
David: And then I I mean more specifically around that image uploader.
VHACLEWahlJ: But well, there's only one
VHACLEWahlJ: one option as far as how that image is going to display on, on there!
David: Yeah.
VHACLEWahlJ: So I I
VHACLEWahlJ: if if that if that's the scenario
VHACLEWahlJ: like again, like I know, if if I go on social media, if I go on Facebook and want to share the Instagram at the same time with some of the the way they have it. I do have to have it formatted in a certain way, so it will display correctly on both. So
VHACLEWahlJ: sometimes Instagram is favored in in their kind of more boxy style, square style photos opposed to how the photographer might send it to me, so it will need to be cropped sometimes. But
David: Yeah, are you familiar with the
David: like? When you upload an image to events, there are size requirements and ratios. In order for event images.
VHACLEWahlJ: Yeah. Philip.
David: Through it. Yeah.
David: So.
VHACLEWahlJ: And I have had some somewhere. There's like a group photos where it was, I guess, a little bit ambiguous, and some of the top, like the higher people in the group, got their head cut off, and it was just really difficult to to merge them into, to fit in there and
VHACLEWahlJ: display correctly.
David: Sorry.
VHACLEWahlJ: Without. I mean, I didn't do any alteration on that photo, but it was
VHACLEWahlJ: sometimes that that could be, and that was an out of control photo. That was a group of.
VHACLEWahlJ: you know, people at a specific event, and it was
VHACLEWahlJ: some milestone they had achieved. And so I I we I don't believe we had a photographer there, so I used that photo. But
David: Yeah.
VHACLEWahlJ: I guess if if this were to be implemented we we could
VHACLEWahlJ: we could do that kind of awareness as best we could, and
VHACLEWahlJ: and I can see a bigger picture where we want to have a uniformity throughout
VHACLEWahlJ: the whole, the whole website like, so when people come to us, they.
VHACLEWahlJ: They recognize the the and feel comfortable with the the layout, so I can see that.
David: Yeah, yeah.
David: Now, are there any features in this updated version that you find confusing or unnecessary?
David: And more specifically around the image uploader?
David: When.
VHACLEWahlJ: No, it I mean it was
VHACLEWahlJ: direct. It would just.
VHACLEWahlJ: I mean, it does have a lot less
VHACLEWahlJ: of those dialogue boxes as far as for cropping like this way, this way, this way, this way. If maybe if there was just a
VHACLEWahlJ: there was a free form.
VHACLEWahlJ: I don't know that that might get messy, too, because people always
VHACLEWahlJ: you know not. Not everyone has an understanding of the graphics. So I suppose that the way this creates it
VHACLEWahlJ: has a little more control, because.
VHACLEWahlJ: being on the other side, even though I'm more hands on in this in this role here, I've I've had even people who work for me who
VHACLEWahlJ: don't quite grasp it, but they not that they need to to do their job, but it just helps keep it clean and keep it looking professional at some level. So
VHACLEWahlJ: I can understand if there were like fewer. Just like if you've been to the in and out, Burger, or you've been to some places where they have a real small menu like you can get 1, 2, or 3, and it it helps reduce versus if you're going to some place like the cheesecake factory, and they have a thousand things on the menu, and it's just overwhelmingly too too much. And for someone who's not familiar with this kind of.
VHACLEWahlJ: you know.
VHACLEWahlJ: graphic interface it. It can be too much for them. It can cause confusion. It can cause.
VHACLEWahlJ: a a lot of
VHACLEWahlJ: just a delay delay, and and that that's has a ripple effect across the board when you're trying to get a lot of content out and and trying to run an office so.
VHACLEWahlJ: Having a a fewer selections like this. This is how we work.
VHACLEWahlJ: I can see that that is a benefit.
VHACLEWahlJ: I mean, if
VHACLEWahlJ: maybe if there's a different version than just this
VHACLEWahlJ: 7 by 2 version or something, typically maybe a.
VHACLEWahlJ: And unless there's statistics to prove that this is this is the best way. But,
VHACLEWahlJ: I don't. I don't have any research on on that aspect, but I like the the idea of having
VHACLEWahlJ: a little bit less.
VHACLEWahlJ: a little bit less. Options like you said, like you mentioned in canva adobe express, or some online quick editor for people, or even all the apps. Now, too, that everyone can go on. You don't have to have any kind of graphics knowledge to go on and crop crop something because they've simplified it so much, and.
David: And.
VHACLEWahlJ: That that I think that will help.
VHACLEWahlJ: And if the end product comes out looking professional.
David: Yeah, I do have a couple last questions for you. Do you ever find yourself using the media library and reusing images that you've already uploaded? Or do you find the majority of the images you're using are new
David: constantly.
VHACLEWahlJ: I. I don't use the media library. I typically even when I'm creating something myself, I typically
VHACLEWahlJ: have updated press content that that comes out it. It would be rare that
VHACLEWahlJ: I think I would spend more time going back to try to find something specific
VHACLEWahlJ: and be then then
VHACLEWahlJ: oh, especially through gerbil. Anyways, you know, if if it's some kind of external content that
VHACLEWahlJ: I'm I'm
VHACLEWahlJ: making for a social media make, we can use adobe stock or something, but and sometimes that's a little bit easier, but not
VHACLEWahlJ: it. It'd be rare that I would, and I again. I I wouldn't eliminate it, but I I wouldn't.
VHACLEWahlJ: I have never used it. So that's what I.
David: Yeah, no. Just curious.
David: The other thing. I'm wondering. Could you go ahead and click that little X on the image? And I'd want to kind of just
David: walk through this upload image flow one more time.
David: Yeah, if you click the blue upload image button.
David: So here on this page 1st of all.
David: what do you think about that? Like those 3 bullets at the top?
David: Are they useful for you?
David: Do you notice them?
VHACLEWahlJ: Hey?
VHACLEWahlJ: I didn't notice them. I went straight. I mean, you have the bold blue and upload image, and that's what I'm looking for.
David: Yeah.
VHACLEWahlJ: Maybe they don't need to be at the
VHACLEWahlJ: top. Maybe if there was like a smaller version down here.
VHACLEWahlJ: Jpeg, I don't know if there's a difference between Jpeg and Jpeg. But
VHACLEWahlJ: just a small.
David: Yeah, I learned, yeah, I learned to like this week that there is a difference. But I it's great that.
VHACLEWahlJ: Okay. I've.
David: That either. Yeah, I agree. That's a
David: money on him.
David: Okay, got it? And then the other thing is one thing I'm not sure, if you've noticed also, is description has now been removed from this version.
David: What do you think about that?
VHACLEWahlJ: Well.
David: And if you'd like a if you'd like to like kind of recall, if you click on the left version on the left map, the current flow you'll be able to
David: be. Oh, yeah, you could also do this way.
David: uploading.
VHACLEWahlJ: Me see if it.
VHACLEWahlJ: This one, I remember, took
VHACLEWahlJ: takes you through a few.
David: Oh, it might take yeah, sometime to upload.
VHACLEWahlJ: And tape.
David: No worries. Take your time. That's
David: Internet.
VHACLEWahlJ: Yeah, I guess
VHACLEWahlJ: so. It it did say that it allows gifs at one time, and I believe we tried to gif, but it it uploaded a gif because I think the it was another PA specialist who wanted to have
VHACLEWahlJ: 2 photos rotate through. But it didn't. When when it went to that
VHACLEWahlJ: external side. It it didn't actually move. It stayed at one photo.
David: Oh, that's interesting. We'll definitely note that
David: for our devs. But so just don't upload properly
David: our end when it.
VHACLEWahlJ: It.
VHACLEWahlJ: He, he!
VHACLEWahlJ: Because he was trying to get around the one photo and and
VHACLEWahlJ: yeah, it seemed like it was working on our side, but not whenever it displayed on the external side.
David: Oh, okay, yeah, we'll definitely note that.
David: So yeah, in this version, as you can see.
David: there's description. And there's no longer description in in this
David: version.
VHACLEWahlJ: I mean
VHACLEWahlJ: i i i guess it, it determined. If
VHACLEWahlJ: it depends on like, if if there's a specific caption information you want to put on there
VHACLEWahlJ: from like I worked with
VHACLEWahlJ: the the defense visual information.
VHACLEWahlJ: distribution hub, and they
VHACLEWahlJ: I mean, if there's a story. They also had a caption with it
VHACLEWahlJ: to maybe clarify what was in the photo that maybe a story wouldn't
VHACLEWahlJ: include, or
VHACLEWahlJ: maybe to clarify a specific
VHACLEWahlJ: piece or person in that photo like this is Dr. Smith and a left, and Dr. Whoever in right? So maybe that that would
VHACLEWahlJ: be a loss at that point. But
VHACLEWahlJ: That's where I would. I would see maybe
VHACLEWahlJ: maybe negative on the lack of the description part.
VHACLEWahlJ: But, I I don't know how it's archived, like everything we archive there was.
VHACLEWahlJ: you know, to be archived for future, for historical reference. But may maybe my understanding here, as far as on
VHACLEWahlJ: just on our
VHACLEWahlJ: va.gov sites. I don't know how
VHACLEWahlJ: actually, I don't know of any archival unit that they use here on
VHACLEWahlJ: on the the Va. Side. I've I've since I've been here. I've
VHACLEWahlJ: I have the content that I've created or used, but
VHACLEWahlJ: where where it goes from there I I don't know. I don't know.
VHACLEWahlJ: So I'm missing that that aspect. So
VHACLEWahlJ: if it doesn't matter.
VHACLEWahlJ: then May, maybe they don't need it. But that that would be one of the questions that would come up in my mind, because when we ever we did any story or for
VHACLEWahlJ: anything in the military they, they always the stories came along with a image or video that had somewhat of a description or caption
VHACLEWahlJ: with with that
VHACLEWahlJ: that imagery, that media.
David: Got it. Got it?
David: Okay? So kind of like, after clicking back and forth between this version and the current version.
David: what stands out to you about this new design.
VHACLEWahlJ: Well, this this one seems like it.
VHACLEWahlJ: more to the point
VHACLEWahlJ: to to okay. I mean, I just want to get this imagery dropped off and get it. Go get it attached, get get it to go with the event, or whatever I need it to go
VHACLEWahlJ: and then save and upload with this one.
VHACLEWahlJ: 1st it went into one
VHACLEWahlJ: one dialogue area, where I selected a photo, and it had me name it. But then I had to go back and come back and rename it again.
VHACLEWahlJ: And I think I think it's just picking the
VHACLEWahlJ: the name of the the file itself
VHACLEWahlJ: description.
VHACLEWahlJ: This, this is the part I don't like is finding where it should go.
VHACLEWahlJ: and
VHACLEWahlJ: octex.
VHACLEWahlJ: and then
VHACLEWahlJ: see. I think people might get
VHACLEWahlJ: confused on this, too, who don't regularly work, because not not every PA specialist who who are on their public affairs. Officer
VHACLEWahlJ: understands all this
VHACLEWahlJ: irregardless because
VHACLEWahlJ: our job is is kind of very wide ranging. We're we're not just doing that one thing. So they just want to get the story out. They want. They want to direct news agencies to come back and maybe use it. Even that we send that we send out press releases. But it's
VHACLEWahlJ: it is kind of a standing location where people can come back and review our stories.
VHACLEWahlJ: Got it.
David: Okay? Well, I have one last question for you.
David: and this is
David: a little bit less about specifically images, more about drupal Cms. As a whole.
David: Is there anything in the current drupal cms that you feel is missing, or could be updated to make your life easier?
David: And this is for future projects that we may consider so if there's anything that you'd like to have improved or you're currently finding, frustrating. Now is the time to share those.
VHACLEWahlJ: Okay,
VHACLEWahlJ: maybe
VHACLEWahlJ: the way we had content. Like, like, for example, we had a research site, that who had more of a rogue
VHACLEWahlJ: site that I mean, it was it was this like a Wix Wix site that they they built to help
VHACLEWahlJ: people who wanted to
VHACLEWahlJ: be part of their research team or had ideas, different things. But we needed to move that under
VHACLEWahlJ: drupal
VHACLEWahlJ: and
VHACLEWahlJ: so it would. So it fall under the Va website. But some of their content, like you said wasn't in the library. So we.
VHACLEWahlJ: because I was struggling with how to get
VHACLEWahlJ: content. That's not specifically Va directives
VHACLEWahlJ: into a site. So if there was a way to mass.
VHACLEWahlJ: bring over everything
VHACLEWahlJ: and attach it and organize that a little better like if you've used like the whizzy wig editor sometimes, or
VHACLEWahlJ: or like like Wix or Squarespace, or a website developer like that, where? Where it's
VHACLEWahlJ: a little more fluid again, I I do see
VHACLEWahlJ: why they're keeping things restricted. But
VHACLEWahlJ: I'm just struggling with
VHACLEWahlJ: when creating the site itself. If I'm not just going back and editing some words, but creating a site from scratch I struggled with how like the visual, what is this looking like? Because it was very slow, like I could go back save the draft, save that, publish it, or whatever, and see what it will look like. But it's very monotonous, this, these steps are so slow. If if there was a way to
VHACLEWahlJ: to expedite that
David: Yeah.
David: anything. Else.
David: I.
VHACLEWahlJ: I guess, just
VHACLEWahlJ: in general.
VHACLEWahlJ: Yeah, May. Maybe I'm talking about the the user interface as well, too, because it
VHACLEWahlJ: it.
VHACLEWahlJ: even though I've gone to the knowledge base and different things I've
VHACLEWahlJ: It's it just seems like it's very restrictive on what you can do. But I I see both sides of that I just was.
VHACLEWahlJ: There's a little cleaner way that we could add some things.
VHACLEWahlJ: I I'm not. I'm not being specific enough for you, but.
David: Well, what kind of things would you want to be able to add that you're currently not able to add.
David: if.
VHACLEWahlJ: Me see if I can.
VHACLEWahlJ: which is
VHACLEWahlJ: recent.
VHACLEWahlJ: This was one I made recently
VHACLEWahlJ: on my page. They they had quite a few.
VHACLEWahlJ: It just gets really in depth, in depth in here, like of layers and layers and layers of of their their content. Because it was. It's actually a pretty big site, but trying to fit it on onto the
VHACLEWahlJ: under the site.
David: oh, I see, there's like 20, something
David: content. This bit, oh, 100, something 100.
VHACLEWahlJ: So yeah, this. This was a big, big job that, but it but it was. It was very.
VHACLEWahlJ: And some of them were like just adding, adding a file.
VHACLEWahlJ: content.
VHACLEWahlJ: mission.
VHACLEWahlJ: and
VHACLEWahlJ: what ways to
VHACLEWahlJ: to add. Add these
VHACLEWahlJ: these links to to different places. If if there was
VHACLEWahlJ: like, I had to upload. What I'm saying is like I had to upload this Pdf file.
VHACLEWahlJ: and I ended up. Just
VHACLEWahlJ: put in them
VHACLEWahlJ: all down here.
VHACLEWahlJ: and then
VHACLEWahlJ: then I couldn't
VHACLEWahlJ: actually find where
VHACLEWahlJ: where that that HTML would would be at, or if I another place I was building
VHACLEWahlJ: a link of just sops. The standard operating procedures.
VHACLEWahlJ: So it's it's already just
VHACLEWahlJ: hard to see. Where was this?
VHACLEWahlJ: Okay, yeah, like this one. So I had to go back
VHACLEWahlJ: and then write like a quick
VHACLEWahlJ: Html code
VHACLEWahlJ: into each of these dialog boxes. So then it, when it would display that people could just go up to here and then click, and then, and
VHACLEWahlJ: it had a controlled
VHACLEWahlJ: location. It was cleaner. But
VHACLEWahlJ: for me to get this
VHACLEWahlJ: get this link. I didn't know where to find it other than to upload the the Pdf. Or wherever this this link was to here, wait till it publish, then click on that link at the bottom and then copy copy
VHACLEWahlJ: up in here in the
VHACLEWahlJ: the HTML.
David: Got it.
VHACLEWahlJ: Site. Then go back, create this code.
VHACLEWahlJ: So this might be.
VHACLEWahlJ: I'm just not familiar with the thing, and I'm I'm I was just tasked with it, and I needed to get it done. But I I wasn't able to find a a better way from the selections here to
VHACLEWahlJ: to just say, I want this
VHACLEWahlJ: this Pdf. To be a clickable link, and I just want to install it and then
VHACLEWahlJ: and go a bit rather than have needing to
VHACLEWahlJ: oops. Go back in
VHACLEWahlJ: type. This code in each time.
David: I see.
David: Okay, well, thank you so much.
David: Thank you so much for your time, and really like we so appreciate you. Taking the time to speak with us. Share your thoughts. Today. Your feedback.
David: Is incredibly helpful as we continue to make the site easier for veterans and editors to use. So, yeah, thank you so much.
VHACLEWahlJ: No, thank you, too, for listening. I I was probably rambling.